speaking of traveling out into deep
space you already mentioned this a
little bit uh
you uh made a beautiful video called The
Journey to the End of the Universe
and sort of at the start of that you're
talking about office Centauri
so what would it take for humans
or for human-like creatures to travel
out to Alpha Centauri
there's a few different ways of doing it
I suppose
um one is it depends on how fast your
ship is that's always going to be the
determining Factor if we devised some
inside proportional system that could
travel a fraction of the speed of light
then we could do it in our lifetimes
which is I think what people normally
dream of when they think about
installing you know proportion and
travel that you could literally step
onto the spacecraft maybe a few years
later you step off and have a century B
you walk around the surface and come
back and visit your family there would
be of course a lot of relativistic time
dilation as a result of that trip you
would have used a lot less than people
back on Earth by traveling close to the
speed of light for some fraction of time
um the challenge of this of course is
that we have no such propulsion system
that can achieve this so which you think
it's possible like uh so yeah
uh you have a paper called the Halo
drive feel free relatively propulsion of
large masses via recycled Boomerang
photons
so uh do you think uh first of all what
is that and second of all uh how
difficult are alternate propulsion
systems
yeah so
the before taking the Halo drive there
was there was an idea because I think
the Halo drive
is not going to solve this problem now
I'll talk about the Halo drive in a
moment but the Halo drive is useful for
a civilization which is a bit more
advanced than this that has spread
across the stars and it's looking for a
cheap highway system to to get across
the Galaxy
for that first step
um because just to context that the the
Halo drive requires black hole so that's
why you're not going to be able to do
this on the Earth right now
um but there are lots of black holes in
the Milky Way if that's the good news so
we'll come to that in a moment but if
you're trying to travel to Alpha
Centauri without a black hole
um then the the most you know there are
some ideas out there there was a project
idalis and project Icarus there were two
projects that the British interplanetary
Society conjured up on sort of a 20 30
year time scale and they asked
themselves if we took existing and
speculatively uh but realistic attempts
at Future technology that are emerging
over the next few decades how far can we
push into that uh travel system and they
settled on Fusion drives in in that so
if we had the ability to essentially uh
either detonate you can also Imagine
That kind of nuclear fission or nuclear
fusion bombs going off behind the
spacecraft and propelling it that way or
having some kind of a successful nuclear
fusion reaction
which obviously we haven't really
demonstrated yet as a propulsion system
then you could achieve something like 10
the speed of light in those systems but
these are
huge spacecrafts and I think you need a
huge spacecraft if you're going to take
people along
um the conversation recently is actually
switched and that's that idea is kind of
seems a little bit Antiquated now and
most of us have kind of given up an idea
of people physically biologically
stepping on board the spacecraft and
maybe we'll be sending something that's
more like a micro probe that maybe just
weighs a gram or two and that's much
easier to accelerate you could push that
with a laser system to very high speed
get it to maybe 20 the speed of light it
has to survive the journey probably a
large fraction of them won't survive the
journey but they're cheap enough that
you could maybe manufacture millions of
them and some of them do arrive and able
to send back an image or maybe even if
you wanted to have a person there we
might have some way of doing like a
telepresence or some kind of delayed
telepresence or
um some kind of reconstruction of the
planet which is sent back so you can
digitally interact with that environment
in a way which is
um not real time but representative of
what that planet would be like to be on
the surface so we might be more like
digital visitors to these plants
certainly far easier practically to do
that than physically forcing this wet
chunk of meat to fly like it across
space to do that
um and so that's maybe uh something we
can imagine down the road the Halo drive
as I said is thinking even further ahead
and if you did want to launch large
masses large masses could even be
planet-sized things in the case of the
Halo drive you can use black holes
so this is kind of
um a trick of physics you know I often
think of the universe as like a big
computer game and you're trying to find
cheat codes hacks exploits that the
Universe didn't intend for you to use
but once you find them you can address
all sorts of interesting capabilities
that you didn't previously have yeah and
the Halo drive does that with black
holes so if you have two black holes
which are very common situation a binary
black hole and they're inspiring towards
each other ligers detected I think
dozens of these things maybe even over
100 at this point
and these things as they merge together
they uh the pre-merger phase they're
they're orbiting each other very very
fast even close to the speed of light
and so Freeman Dyson uh before he passed
away I think in the 70s had this
provocative paper called gravitational
machines and he suggested that you could
use neutron stars as a Interstellar
propulsion system
and neutron stars are sort of the uh
the you know the lower Mass version of
binary black hole system essentially
in this case he suggested just doing
gravitational slingshot just fly your
spacecraft into this uh very Compact and
relativistic binary system and you do
need neutron stars because if there were
two stars they'd be physically touching
each other so the neutron stars are so
small like 10 kilometers across they can
get really close to each other and have
these very very fast orbits with respect
to each other
you shoot your spacecraft through right
through the middle like throwing through
the eye of a needle and you do a
slingshot around one of them and you do
it around the one that's coming sort of
towards you so when I'm becoming where
you want to be coming towards you any
one point and then you could basically
steal some of the kinetic energy in the
slingshot in principle you can sell up
to twice the speed you can take your
speed and it becomes your speed plus
twice the speed of the black of the
neutron star in this case and that would
be your new speed after the slingshot
this seems great because it's just free
energy basically you're not doing it you
know you're not generally to have a
nuclear power react or anything to
generate this you're just stealing it
and indeed you can get to relativistic
speeds this way so I loved that paper
but I had a criticism and the criticism
was that this is like trying to fly your
ship into a blender right this is this
is two neutron stars which have huge
tidal forces
um and they're whipping around each
other once every second or even less
than a second and you're trying to fly
your spaceship and do this maneuver that
is pretty precarious and so it just
didn't seem practical to me to do this
but I loved it and so I I took that idea
and this is how science is it's
iterative it's it's you take a previous
great man's idea and you just sort of
maybe slightly tweak it and improve it
that's how I see the Halo drive and I
just suggested why not replace those out
for black holes
which is certainly very common and
rather than flying your ship into that
uh that hell hole of a blender System
you just stand back and you fire a laser
beam now because black holes have such
intense gravitational fields they can
bend light into complete 180s they can
actually become mirrors so you know the
sun bends light by maybe a fraction of a
degree through gravitational lensing but
you know a compact object like a black
hole can do a full 180 in fact if you
obviously if if you went too close if
you put the laser beam too close to the
black hole just fall into it and never
come back out so you just kind of push
it out push it out push it out until you
get to a point where it's just skirting
The Event Horizon and then that laser
beam skirts around it comes back now the
laser beam wants to do a gravity I mean
it is doing a gravitational slingshot
but laser I mean light photons can't
speed up unlike in like the spaceship
case so instead of speeding up the way
they steal energy is they they increase
their frequency so they become higher
energy Photon packets essentially and
they get blue shifted so that you send
maybe a red laser beam that comes back
blue it's got more energy in it and
because
um photons carry momentum which is
somewhat unintuitive in everyday
experience but they do that's how solar
cells work they can't momentum they push
things you can even use them as laser
tweezers and things to pick things up
um because they push the Met it comes
back with more momentum than it left so
you get an acceleration force from this
and again you're just seeing energy from
the black hole to do this so you can get
up to the same speed it's basically the
same idea as Freeman Dyson but doing it
from a safer distance and there should
be a border of you know a million or so
or 10 million black holes in the Milky
Way galaxy
some of them would be even as close as
sort of 10 to 20 light years when you do
the occurrence rate statistics of how
close you might expect feasibly want to
be they're of course difficult to detect
because they're black so they're
inherently hard to see but statistically
there should be plenty out there in the
Milky Way and so these objects would be
natural Waypoint stations you could use
them to both accelerate away and to
break and slow down
and on top of all this you know there's
we've been talking about astronomy and
cosmology there's been a lot of exciting
uh breakthroughs in detection and
exploration of uh black holes so the the
boomerang boomeranging photons that
you're talking about there's been a lot
of work on photon rings and just all the
fun stuff going on outside the black
holes yeah
um so all the the garbage outside is
actually might be the thing that holds a
key to understanding what's going on
inside and there's the Hawking radiation
there's all kinds of fascinating stuff
like uh I mean they're just trippy stuff
about black holes that I can't even well
most people don't understand I mean the
holographic
principle with the plate and the
information being stored potentially
outside of the black hole
I don't even I can't even comprehend how
you can project a three-dimensional
object up to 2D and some hostile
information where it doesn't destroy it
and if it does destroy it uh challenging
all the physics all of this is very
uh interesting
especially for kind of more practical
applications of how the black hole could
be used for propulsion yeah I mean it
may be that black holes are used in all
sorts of ways
um by Advanced civilizations I think uh
again it's been a popular idea in
science fiction or science fiction Trope
that Sagittarius star the supermassive
black hole and the certified Galaxy
could be the best place to look for
intelligent life in the universe because
it is a giant uh engine in a way you
know a unique capability for black hole
is you can basically throw matter into
it and you can get these jets that come
out the accretion disks and the jets
that fly out and so you can more or less
use them to convert matter into energy V
equals mc squared and there's pretty
much nothing else except for you know
Annihilation with and with its own
antiparticle as a way of doing that
so they have some unique properties you
could perhaps power a civilization
registering garbage into a black hole
right just throwing asteroids in and how
your civilization with as much energy as
you really would ever plausibly need and
you could also use them to accelerate
away Across the Universe and you can
even imagine using small artificial
black holes as thermal generators right
so the Hawking radiation from them kind
of exponentially increases as they get
smaller and smaller in size and so a
very small black hole one that you can
almost imagine like holding in your hand
would be a fairly significant heat
Source
um and so that raises all sorts of
prospects about how you might use that
in an engineering context to power your
civilization as well